hey guys it's Justine and I wanted
update you guys on vlogs University
because it is gonna be here before you
know it now if you guys don't know I'm
holding a conference here in Los Angeles
for you guys to learn about content
creation
I know it's called vlog University but I
don't want you to think that this is
just focusing on vlogging because it is
so much more the next 50 people who
register by December 28th will be
entered into a raffle to win some ear
pods that also get some free vlog you
swag I feel like the word vlog sometimes
has this connotation of running around
filming yourself but I think this is a
vlog and to create this little vlog
right here we have kind of an insane
setup we have two cameras we have mics
we have lighting we have secret lights
underneath here so much goes into
content creation that a lot of people
have no idea about so we wanted to have
this two-day conference basically a
crash course of content creation from
editing lighting production marketing
and everything in between of creating
content for the internet now it can be
for YouTube it could be for Instagram
whatever that is we want to give you
guys the tools and the resources and
meet other like-minded people just like
you but have no idea where to start and
if you do know where to start and if
you're already a creator there are so
much more that you can learn here but
it's not just for beginners it's really
exciting because we do have support from
Apple so obviously I'm a huge Final Cut
Editor so we'll be having a bunch of
Final Cut classes I also did a Final Cut
tutorial if you guys have never seen
that I'll also put a link in the
description but the guys from ripple
training who worked with me on that
tutorial will also be here so the people
that we have teaching these courses are
not just people who just started editing
yesterday they have been doing this for
a really long time so I cannot wait for
you guys to learn from some of the best
people in the industry not only will we
be having a lot of these great speakers
but I will be there I'll be holding a
bunch of sessions I'll be leading panels
and I'll be around those two days to
meet you guys hang out say hi take
pictures but mostly I don't want this to
be just sort of like a meet and greet
type thing I want you guys to come here
and
meet other people who are doing the same
thing as you I really want you guys to
leave this two-day conference with the
knowledge to create and if you're
already creating I want you to be little
take what you're doing and up that so
that you can start creating even more
high quality content there are a bunch
of questions since my last video so I
want to make sure that I answer all of
those a lot of you were asking how old
do you have to be it is an 18 and over
conference but if you are fourteen or
older you are able to attend but you'll
need a chaperone who is at least 18
years old and you'll have to sign a
waiver for more information and anything
else that I didn't cover check out the
link in the description and there's also
a little contact us but you can ask the
team here any questions that you guys
have regarding the conference so don't
be afraid to reach out if there's
something that we can help you with
they've updated an FAQ so hopefully any
of the questions that you guys have been
asking maybe on the website there's also
recording options so if you guys don't
happen to be in this area and not able
to travel for the event there will be a
recording option where you can buy all
of the recordings of everything that has
happened at the conference if this is
something that you're really serious
about and there's other sessions that
you won't be able to make it to with
this recording option you'll be able to
have a recording of all of the sessions
over those two days we've also now added
a payment plan option so I know the
tickets are a little expensive so if
this is something that you were looking
forward to and wanted to attend but
didn't want to pay for it all upfront we
do have that option now add it to the
website we'll have a really fun Expo
night so we're gonna have a bunch of
really fun sponsors so during Expo night
I'll be hanging out there a bunch of the
sponsors will be and all of the other
attendees so it'll be a really great
place where you guys can all hang out
meet other people who will be here for
vlog University I'm just mostly excited
about all loopy sessions because there's
a lot of really great sessions and some
of them are not entirely fleshed out yet
we're still working on the schedules
we'll have some surprise guest speakers
which won't be a surprise when we
announce them but right now we're still
working on all of that stuff we're still
about a month ish out I can't believe
how soon it's good
here but I know it's gonna be so much
fun and I can't wait to see all of you
guys there again our holiday promo is
gift 20 so if you guys use that anytime
in December you get 20% off your ticket
price so make sure when you go to
checkout you use that code so you'll get
a discount well thank you guys for
watching this quick update video I'm so
excited I have a bunch more videos
coming up very shortly and if there's
any other sessions that you can't be
interested in seeing it vlog University
leave those in the comments below and I
hope to see you guys there also be sure
to follow our Instagram vlog University
and we are also on Twitter at vlog
University I will see you guys in my
next video I cannot wait for this
conference it's gonna be so much fun and
I cannot wait to teach you guys some of
the things that I've learned over the
course of 13 plus years of making videos
on YouTube
[Music]